[Música]
en primera plana
carlos cerrar
[Música]
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio francia internacional de france
24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
colombia donde se abre una nueva era
histórica con la toma de posesión de
gustavo petro su primer presidente de
izquierdas el próximo 7 de agosto
analizamos los nuevos retos para
colombia con nuestros invitados hoy
ángela salgado beltrán politólogo y
observadora electoral bienvenida angela
muchas gracias por la invitación nos
acompaña también civil benoit es miembro
de la misión observación electoral en
colombia y forma parte del sector
internacional del partido comunista
francés bienvenidos civil buenos días
gracias por invitación y nos acompaña
también en dúplex guilén pérez
periodista en le parisian y autora del
libro tras los pasos de álvaro uribe
vélez bienvenida a glen muy buenos días
carlos y muy buenos días a todos los
invitados y a los espectadores que nos
están mirando gracias por la intención
explorar
gustavo petro nueva era en colombia hoy
nuestro asunto en primera plana
el presidente electo de colombia gustavo
petro es el primer presidente de
izquierdas que gobernará el país en su
historia pero se posesiona este 7 de
agosto según dicta la tradición política
del país para entrar a la casa de nariño
y ejercer el cargo de presidente hasta
2026 ese mismo día el presidente iván
duque termina mandato luego del
juramento se impone la banda
presidencial y a partir de ahí enormes
retos a los que le esperan al nuevo
presidente pero sobre la mesa recibirá
un país con altos niveles de pobreza
desigualdad tendrá que restablecer la
economía también la educación impulsar
nuevos acuerdos de paz pero para muchos
analistas quizás sea la seguridad su
mayor desafío repasemos algunas portadas
la edición extraordinaria de la revista
colombiana semana con la victoria de
petró y su vicepresidenta francia
márquez también la revista rolling
stones ha dedicado precisamente su
portada francia- márquez bajo el titular
un compromiso por la reparación el
diario el colombiano recoge las palabras
que le dijo el saliente duque al
presidente electo petro éxitos en su
gestión eso sí dice el periódico duque
le recordó que se puede trabajar el agro
sin expropiaciones bueno angela una
nueva era para colombia algo desconocido
para el país se abre ahora me imagino
que ilusiones quizá el paso del tiempo y
la erosión política quizá puede que
también haya decepciones cómo ve esta
nueva etapa que se abre para el país va
al haber con muchísimas muchísimas
expectativas y esperanzas
efectivamente es un momento histórico
que nos llena de mucha ilusión sobre
todo creo que hay mucha expectativa por
la llegada de nuevos actores sociales a
instancias de poder
que históricamente han sido excluidos de
los lugares de toma de decisiones
también por la implementación o posible
implementación de un plan de gobierno
que es bastante avanzado y usado en
muchos temas por ejemplo en todo lo que
tiene que ver con los derechos de las
mujeres la creación de un sistema
nacional de cuidados y la creación de un
ministerio de la igualdad que son
políticas bastante nuevas dentro de
nuestro sistema
claro en el pagas civil cuando las
expectativas son tantas la ilusión es
tanta y las ambiciones tan altas también
las decepciones pueden serlo el bono sí
yo creo que de hecho esto va a ser uno
de los desafíos del gobierno porque como
se dijo se llegó después de un
movimiento social muy fuerte una
situación social muy complicada en todo
el territorio nacional y que las
expectativas van en todos los ámbitos no
y bueno pero va a tener que priorizar
buscar acuerdos consensos para pasar
legislación y esto va a tomar tiempo
porque además es el primer presidente
sectores alternativos en 200 años de
historia republicana y son estructuras
también profundas que se toca modificar
y eso no se lleva a cabo en cuatro años
pero la gran esperanza que arranca con
petro es lograr una agenda de justicia
social luego de un periodo de pandemia y
de estallido social
como creen que va a resolver petro las
fracturas que se han abierto entre la
institucionalidad y la ciudadanía
colombiana ángela bueno pues en este
caso nos tenemos que preguntar primero
por qué inició este estadio social en el
año 2019 recordar que esto fue a raíz de
un descontento generalizado que se
catalizó a través de las declaraciones
del ministro de la época sobre la
reforma tributaria
entonces en ese sentido y después de la
pandemia con unas cifras de pobreza
elevadas
una de las vías que tiene petropar a
poder afrontar estas fracturas que hay
es precisamente pueden ser en una
presentar y llevar a cabo una reforma
tributaria que justamente subsane
la situación ocasionada en el 2019 una
reforma tributaria que tenga impuestos
progresistas justamente y segundo lo que
promete en su plan del gobierno que es
una de las cosas centrales en la campaña
que es la reforma a la policía que se
plantea que igual tiene muchos retos que
afrontar en en este tema
civil bueno yo creo que las fracturas
son en los niveles sociales regionales
étnicas
y va a tener que llevar a cabo este
programa reconstruir el estado yo creo
que es el 1er
como el primer desafío que tiene pero
también sanear lo que ya existe y esto
va a ser otro eje de trabajo complejo en
dúplex recuerdo tenemos aquí leen pérez
periodista en el diario le parisien y
autora del libro tras los pasos de
álvaro uribe chrysler usted ha
documentado durante muchos años la
violencia en colombia y de hecho se
temía un está ayuda de violencia o
incluso un magnicidio al conocerse los
resultados de los comicios al final todo
este período de transición entre la
presencia de duke y la presidencia de
petró está transcurriendo de forma
pacífica con gestos fuertes de
reconciliación podríamos decir que ha
cambiado en el país
creo que el primer cambio es que el
pueblo ha elegido un presidente que ha
denunciado toda su vida la corrupción el
paramilitarismo los nexos con la
política y el paramilitarismo y el
narcotráfico la desigualdad que es un ex
integrante del m-19 y la vicepresidenta
que es negra de origen humilde y
luchadora por el medio ambiente los que
van a dirigir el país a partir de ahora
no están desconectados con el pueblo
ninguno de los dos viene de la
oligarquía el segundo cambio es que otra
vez pues hay una real esperanza en la
paz se ha nombrado un comisionado de
alto comisionado de la paz
se va a crear ministerio de la paz de la
seguridad y de la convivencia
a la cual al cual pasará la policía que
ya no va a tener un carácter militar
sino civil y hay una gran esperanza
sobre todo de empezar otra vez diálogos
con el adn ya que el l n se expresó en
este sentido y petro ha tendido la mano
para para empezar estos diálogos hay un
cambio en la cultura política que uno
puede notar que hasta ahora no hay
cacería de brujas hay una política de
apertura
hubo un hecho contundente que fue el
encuentro entre estado petro y álvaro
uribe yo no creo que si había sido
elegido con gutiérrez o rodolfo
hernández este tipo de encuentro hubiera
sido posible
claro hablaba en los diálogos de paz con
el gobierno de duke la agenda de paz
estuvo estancada abrir nuevos procesos
de paz y acelerar con los que ya existe
será quizá uno de los cambios más
significativos que a lo mejor civil
encontremos con el mandato de petro
desde el principio ahora acabamos de ver
como boris ha invitado a que se a que
comiencen en chile esos diálogos con el
l en lo ofrecido a la vicepresidenta
márquez sí yo creo que no se trata sobre
todo abrir nuevos procesos de fas sino
aplicar primero de los acuerdos de más
del 2016 con las fans porque eso
y prevé muchos mecanismos que son
fundamentales para tener las cosas
fundan bueno que le dan origen a la
violencia en colombia que es la
desigualdad la sustitución de cultivos
ilícitos la reforma agraria etcétera
pues por una parte implementar este
acuerdo de paz que no sólo se estancó
sino que se quiso desmontar con iván
duque y reanudar los diálogos y las
negociaciones de paz con el eln que es
un actor político militar pero que tiene
una visión política y que en el 2019 se
abre un proceso de negociaciones que se
suspendió con iván duque y yo creo que
primero tocaré abrir este diálogo con
lln vemos que si hay perspectivas y
luego se da también el tema de los
actores armados más ligados al
narcotráfico que son actores criminales
y que suponen mecanismos distintos para
lograr su desmovilización claro que
además conseguir éxitos de paz es
incluso un revulsivo para las
inversiones extranjeras y la imagen del
país la imagen que proyecta colombia el
mundo no congela si justamente uno de
los temas que muy en boga en los últimos
días es esta expresión de la paz total y
de la posibilidad de entrar en
negociaciones con otros actores tales
como el clan del golfo
sin embargo es un tema considero
bastante espinoso
por las características que tiene una
estructura como el plan como el clan del
golfo en qué términos se van a reconocer
en qué términos se van a hacer las
negociaciones no no estamos hablando
necesariamente de los mismos actores en
este momento el clan del golfo tiene un
plan pistola
en la región que controla y van más de
30 policías asesinados durante el año y
fueron que provocaron justo creo que
fueron tres o cuatro semanas antes de
las elecciones no claro entonces pues yo
creo que el tema de la negociación con
este tipo de actores es uno de los
puntos álgidos de esta
propuesta de la paz total no no no no
parece tan
claro como como esto se puede llevar a
cabo sobre todo en términos de
de las condiciones de justicia que se
tienen que dar para abrir una
negociación así vamos a ir avanzando
porque muchos temas sobre la mesa está
la paz pero también tenemos que hablar
de economía e incluso del propio estilo
de liderazgo porque petro llegar a la
presidencia envuelto en algunos ejes de
incertidumbre en primer lugar cuál va a
ser su estilo de liderazgo en varias
ocasiones civil se le ha acusado de no
admitir bien las divergencias al
presidente electo bueno yo sí creo que
es un líder con una personalidad fuerte
esto lo hemos podido ver en la en el
período también de que se gestó el pacto
histórico no que fue una agrupación de
distintos sectores y fuerzas y que unos
quedaron apartados o
inconformes con lo que resultó ser el
pacto sin embargo yo creo que la misma
estructura es una cosa es ser candidato
una cosa es el líder y otra cosa es el
previamente cierto y que hay con la
estructura en el parlamento en el
congreso pero también la estructura
social y de su coalición de gobierno va
a tener que discutir con muchos sectores
entonces yo creo que si hay el temor es
que haya como acaparamiento de poder yo
no lo veo como un riesgo real y yo creo
que ya se ha comprimido al dejar el
poder después de este mandato y que
bueno lo va a cumplir yo no leo una
trayectoria de riesgo dictatorial el
mantener la unión importante no sé no
concuerdo con lo que dice civil pero
además quiero agregar que
durante este periodo después de su
elección de la segunda vuelta ha
mostrado algunas de sus características
sobre su talante como mandatario lo
primero que quiero resaltar obviamente
el encuentro con sus opositores con
hernández con álvaro uribe pero además
miremos también el gabinete que ha
seleccionado realmente de los ministros
y ministras que hasta ahora están hay
uno o dos que son realmente petris estás
vienen muy muy fuertes personas de
sectores liberales e históricos del
partido liberal
les voy a preguntar por eso por la
formación del gabinete los nombres que
de los que ya se ha hablado hacemos una
breve pausa volvemos en seguir
analizando la nueva era de petró en
colombia que en primera plana
enlace del conosur a norteamérica de los
andes' a centroamérica una cita semanal
con los temas más importantes de los
países del continente americano
presentada por los corresponsales de
france 24
enlace en france 24 y france 24 puntocom
porque la historia se escribe día a día
porque la actualidad no espera la
información dondequiera que esté en
cualquier circunstancia
todos los temas para entender el mundo
para imaginar el mundo
france24 una mirada diferente liberté
égalité actually team
seguimos en primera plana esta semana
hablando de colombia' de la nueva etapa
que se abra con petro en el poder a
partir del 7 de agosto lo hacemos con
ángela salgado beltrán politóloga civil
benoit miembro de la misión observación
electoral en colombia y forma parte del
sector internacional del partido
comunista francés y en dúplex con guild
en pérez periodista en el diario le
parisien y autora del libro tras los
pasos de álvaro uribe antes de la pausa
estaba comentando angela las
características de ese gobierno de petro
los nombres no sé si querrían destacar
algunos nombres que les han podido
llamar la atención si dilo angela bueno
yo creo yo destacaría el nombramiento de
iván velásquez yo creo que ha sido de
momento el nombramiento más impactante
que ha hecho gustavo petro por la
trayectoria que tiene en términos de
lucha por los derechos humanos contra la
corrupción tanto en colombia con el tema
de la parapolítica como en guatemala con
la comisión internacional contra la
impunidad que tuvo grandes éxitos en la
lucha contra la corrupción y pues porque
su nombramiento en el ministerio de
defensa que es un ministerio clave
para implementar esta senda que
comentábamos de derechos humanos de
cambiar la relación de la fuerza pública
con la población en colombia y salir de
un enfoque totalmente represivo pues
debe preguntar también sobre esta
cuestión guilén pérez porque y conocemos
a varias figuras clave que van a
conformar el gobierno que mensaje está
mandando ya a petro desde desde ya el
presidente electo creo que uno de estos
nombres es el de álvaro leiva como
canciller
y otra vez eso muestra la apertura y el
deseo de unión de que todas las fuerzas
se unen para trabajar porque álvaro
leyva al principio de su carrera venid
ante el partido conservador
es una señal fuerte también porque ahí
tienen buenas relaciones con eeuu y ya
empezó a reunirse con diplomáticos de
eeuu es un proceso del día la
normalización de relaciones con
venezuela
leiva él mismo dijo que sería una
cancillería de la paz él investigó las
alianzas de empresarios políticos
militares con los grupos paramilitares y
es un mundo poderoso al país de que la
paz es prioridad del nuevo gobierno la
apertura es también de
nombrar ministros que ejercieron en
gobierno de santos o que vienen de otras
coaliciones que se presentaron en contra
de él durante la primera vuelta también
el señal es el de aplicar la paridad
elio varios puestos ministros
ministerios perdón importantes a mujeres
el ministerio de salud de la agricultura
de la cultura yo opino también una
especie de paridad no sé si se puede
hacer decir así pero hay jóvenes en este
gobierno y gente que tiene más de 70
años
la diversidad
y helio opuestos a indígenas
afrocolombianos un puesto tan importante
como la embajada de washington la
embajada de colombia en washington
perdón que es uno de los cargos
diplomáticos más importantes del país
a quien lo dio pues lo yo
gilberto murillo y luis roberto murillo
acumula es decir fue la fórmula de
sergio fajardo fue el ex ministro de
ambiente de
té santos y es afro colombiano bueno
estamos analizando esa composición del
gobierno estoy hablando sobre todo
también de esas relaciones exteriores
que va a establecer a partir de ahora
colombia uno de los principales retos
sin duda para petro y les quiero
preguntar lógicamente por venezuela cómo
se van a reconstruir esas relaciones con
caracas civil o angela porque es avatar
sí o no ese también es uno de los temas
espinosos sin embargo recordar que en la
campaña una de las de sus promesas de
campaña fue precisamente real reactivar
la relación diplomática con venezuela
entendiendo al gobierno de venezuela en
la lógica del reconocimiento de la
autonomía de los
reconociendo la validez de su gobierno y
reabriendo las relaciones esto también
tiene que ver con tanto la crisis
humanitaria que se vivió que se vive hoy
en día junto con la reactivación
económica de la frontera esos son como
como los dos su posición hasta ahora lo
que sabemos que va a pasar con venezuela
otro tema muy espinoso el de venezuela
pero otro que también lo es tras la
posesión los militares tendrán que jurar
lealtad a un ex miembro de las
guerrillas izquierdistas que han
combatido durante seis décadas de
conflicto a finales de abril petro acusó
a miembros de la cúpula militar de estar
aliados con el clan del golfo la mayor
banda de narcos del país como se va a
restablecer la confianza tan dañada de
petro con el estamento militar civil
bueno yo creo que petro ha sido claro de
que lo que pide al ejército no es que se
le sea fiel a gustavo petro sino que le
sea fiel a la constitución colombiana
ahora eso es más fácil decirlo que hacer
no sé al aro porque es un ejército que
ha sido
como bajo la doctrina de la seguridad
nacional desde su propia creación no
le va a tocar un proceso largo de
adaptación y de cambio de mentalidad de
cambio de doctrina militar que ya se ha
intentado con el acuerdo de paz pero que
viva en duke volvió a acercar a la
doctrina de seguridad nacional y una
politización también y yo creo que hay
señales que son preocupantes como el
general zapatero cuando
dejó su puesto y dijo que se iba a él
pero que quedan muchos zapateros en el
ejército dejando ciertas amenazas sin
embargo yo creo que ahí se inscribe el
nombramiento de iván velázquez para
atender esta parte de derechos humanos
pero también está esos lazos que sí
existen entre sectores del ejército y
buenos grupos armados ilegales bandas
criminales por una parte y otro elemento
que quisiera destacar en este aspecto es
yo creo que la sociedad colombiana
también va cambiando su percepción
de la fuerza pública y en el yo juega un
papel muy importante la justicia
transicional las el informe de la de la
comisión de la verdad y escándalos
recientes que tuvieron como muertes de
civiles en varias selecciones del país
no llevan un poco
rompiendo la unanimidad acerca de las
fuerzas militares y las incita a cambiar
un poco su rumbo vuelvo en dúplex con
killer pérez periodista de le parisien y
autora del libro tras los pasos de
álvaro uribe un libro en el que
documenta el recorrido del ex presidente
colombiano y sus vínculos turbios con
los narcos su delfín duque está por
dejarle a la presidencia y su candidato
el cazador federico fico gutiérrez fue
derrotado en la primera vuelta de los
comicios
se puede adivinar qué papel jugará el
uribismo esta vez en la oposición
petro dijo que la oposición siempre será
la bienvenida en el parasol en 'la para
conversar de los problemas del país y su
meta es un acuerdo nacional
hace algunos días el centro democrático
salió anunció que iba a ejercer esta
oposición precisamente ellos dijeron que
con un espíritu patriótico entre
comillas con argumentos y a través de un
canal de ayer walk directo es cierto que
ellos se van a oponer en materia de
reforma de impuestos de reforma agraria
de los acuerdos de paz de la reforma
pensional de la salud y además que todos
ellos pretenden defender la fuerza
pública a la policía porque estiman que
está en peligro y más que todo yo creo
que ven como una amenaza del
nombramiento del ministro de defensa que
si van velázquez
él se ha opuesto mucho prima álvaro
uribe que lo ha señalado como de
corromper la justicia es el ex
magistrado de la corte suprema de
justicia él investigó mucho también la
poblada la parapolítica y por eso su
nombramiento genera un miedo dentro del
centro democrático ya que es considerado
como un medio vivo entonces yo pienso
que sí va a ser la principal fuerza de
oposición
pero el uribismo yo creo que con la
presidencia de duke con los escándalos
de los 'falsos positivos' de la
parapolítica y además con el cansancio
del pueblo con las maquinarias el
uribismo es bien lejos de sus horas
fases cosas no no diría que está
completamente al piso y yo pienso que el
hecho de que va a ser la única fuerza de
oposición o una de las únicas fuerzas de
oposición le va a dar un poquito más de
fuerza ahora que no están al poder el
gobierno de petro va a ser un gobierno
de transición en cuatro años no se puede
cambiar absolutamente todo se puede
mostrar un camino se pueden cambiar se
puede impulsar un nuevo sistema y
entonces es seguro que el primer
escándalo de corrupción pues porque la
corrupción casi fue se volvió cultura en
colombia es no se puede erradicar así
como así entonces el primer escándalo de
corrupción algo de clientelismo álbum
será un arma que el organismo se va a
poder se va a apoderar desde ar como lo
ven en la posición del uribismo hay un
abismo sin uribe quizás a la primera
pregunta angela yo creo que no podemos
entrar en esta retórica de que el
uribismo ha muerto o que ya no está
presente que rescatando los medios
plantearlas y hay que recordar que el
centro democrático tiene una fuerza en
el congreso tiene una fuerza en el
senado hay que recordar que vienen las
elecciones regionales
y que además de eso tiene un líder
natural que todavía sigue presente
no creo que es que podamos estar de
nuevo en esta en esta dinámica de pensar
que no son un actor nacional super
relevante hay que recordar que petro no
gana con una amplia mayoría sí que hay
varias regiones donde claramente perdió
donde tanto resonantes como el centro
democrático mantienen sus caudales
políticos y lo segundo es que a pesar de
que hoy con las alianzas que se han
hecho en las últimas semanas
efectivamente haya una coalición de
mayorías esta coalición sigue siendo
débil es decir no podemos decir que lo
acordado hasta horita va a mantenerse
durante los próximos cuatro años
entonces yo sí creo que hay una
oposición que sigue estando presente y
sigue siendo fuerte civil si yo es
cierto que el uribismo pasa por una
crisis porque fico ni siquiera fue su
propuesta original de candidato sin
embargo yo creo que expresa unos
intereses que se mantienen vivos en
colombia que se van a oponer al gobierno
el sector ganadero otros sectores como
este y que pueden encontrar otro
vehículo que no está propiamente mismo
que es una expresión histórica de la
extrema derecha de ciertos intereses y
también yo toca creo verlo en
perspectiva regional e internacional que
la extrema derecha figuras como
bolsonaro cast se van produciendo mucho
por todos países y colombiano se escapa
de este panorama lo que parece claro es
que la llegada al poder de la izquierda
en colombia sí que completa el proceso
de des estigmatización que tenía la
izquierda en el país es decir eso sí que
ya está ahí no angela yo en este punto
no concuerdo creo que la estigmatización
o sea el hecho de que petro llegue al
poder no necesariamente implica un
proceso de des estigmatización la
estigmatización de la izquierda puede
verse en un espectro muy grande
recordemos que al día de hoy más de 300
ex firmantes de paz asesinados
desde el 2016
recordemos que a pesar de que hasta el
momento la transición se ha dado de
manera no violenta lo cual habla muy
bien de nuestro sistema político la
violencia política existe y se agudiza
más de 1300 líderes sociales asesinados
y quienes tanto esta expresión de
estigmatización como las expresiones más
si se quiere menos menos directas como
por ejemplo todas las críticas que hubo
con la presencia de ciertos actores de
la izquierda en la posición del congreso
me voy a porque me quedo sin tiempo para
más muchísimas gracias a los tres a
todos ustedes nos tomamos arrom parón
este mes de agosto para necesitamos las
vacaciones este equipo por nosotros
volvemos en septiembre se queda en
agosto con una selección de los mejores
programas y aprovechó dos minutos
finales para agradecer a todo el equipo
por la temporada ya ambos de las en la
realización van y salva son el sonido
matías taylor fabián mujeres y por
supuesto fue florencia valdés la
coordinadora de este programa a todos
ustedes nos vemos en septiembre muchas
gracias
[Música]